en el último vídeo vimos que podemos
tomar un sistema de ecuaciones con dos
ecuaciones y dos incógnitas y lo
representamos con una ecuación matricial
la matriz am la tomamos como los
coeficientes de las ecuaciones que tengo
aquí a la izquierda y el vector columna
x es la representación de las variables
ese ítem y por último el vector columna
haber simplemente representa la parte
derecha de estas ecuaciones y bueno lo
interesante lo que llegamos en el vídeo
pasado es que esto lo podemos
representar como la matriz andy que
multiplica el vector columna x y que
esto es igual al vector columna vez pero
es lo padre de esto es que nos dimos
cuenta de que si es invertible entonces
multiplicando por la izquierda ambos
lados de esta ecuación y ojo
multiplicamos el lado izquierdo de esta
ecuación pues en este caso si importa el
orden en que multiplicamos las matrices
por eso nos estamos tomando la
multiplicación por el lado izquierdo
entonces si multiplicamos la izquierda
de la ecuación por la inversa obtenemos
que podemos resolver de una manera
sencilla para el doctor columna equis y
una vez que sepamos cuánto vale el
vector columna x entonces ya sabemos
cuánto vale s
y con eso logramos solucionar el sistema
de ecuaciones así que bueno es momento
de resolverlo vamos a averiguar cuánto
vale la matriz inversa de amd y
multipliquemos la por el vector columna
p y cuál es o obtendremos el valor de
ese ítem así que a inversa ésta va a ser
igual a 1 entre el determinante de amp
pero bueno en el caso de una matriz de
dos por dos el determinante de asse
obtiene una manera muy sencilla
multiplicando ambos lo siguiente vamos a
multiplicar a 2 por 4 ya eso le vamos a
restar la multiplicación de menos dos
por menos 5 y eso es bueno pues 2 por 4
es 88 menos menos 2 por menos 5 es 10
positivo por lo tanto nos va a quedar 8
menos 10 y bueno eso es lo mismo que
menos 2 y es más vamos a corroborar lo
para ver que no nos hayamos equivocado 2
por 4 es 88 - a menos 2 por menos 5 es
10 positivo ocho menos diez es menos dos
ok entonces me queda 1
entre el determinante de am por la
matriz adjunta de am y esa matriz recibe
es el nombre adjunta de am porque
esencialmente se obtiene intercambiando
la entrada superior izquierda con la
inferior derecha esto en una matriz de
dos por dos así que este de aquí se
vuelve un cuatro y este de aquí se va a
volver un 2 y después hay que hacer
estos dos negativos la versión negativa
de los que son actualmente así que de
menos 2 es 2 y de menos 5 es 5 si todo
esto te suena demasiado extraño debería
repasar el tutorial de matrices inversas
pues es todo lo que estamos viendo aquí
así que a inversa va a ser igual am y
bueno sí multiplicó el menos un medio
por cada una de estas entradas me
quedaría menos un medio por 4 eso es lo
mismo que menos 2 después tengo menos 1
entre 2 x 5 menos un medio por 5 bueno
pues se encuentra 2 es lo mismo que
cinco medios o 2.5 entonces me quedaría
menos 2.5 después tengo menos un medio x
bueno eso es menos 1 y menos un medio
por 2 es menos 1 así que aquí tenemos ya
por fin nuestra matriz inversa de a así
que ahora vamos a multiplicar a esta
matriz inversa por el vector columna 7
menos 6 así que déjame poner aquí a la
matriz inversa que obtuvimos que es este
de aquí me quedan menos 2 menos 2.5
menos 1 y menos uno ok a esta matriz la
voy a multiplicar por el vector columna
7 menos 6 y bueno nosotros ya tenemos un
montón de práctica multiplicando
matrices así que esto creo que va a ser
muy sencillo y bueno nuestra primera
entrada va a salir de multiplicar el
menos dos ok este menos 2 por el 7 lo
cual bueno esos menos 14 ok ya esto
habrá que sumarle menos 2.5 por menos 6
y bueno menos por menos es más
ok y después me queda 2.5 por 6 6 por 2
es 12 12 3 es 15 15 positivo entonces me
va a quedar menos 14 más 15 ok y después
tengo menos 1
lo cuales siete ya esto le voy a sumar
menos 1 x menos 6 lo cual es seis
positivos ok entonces esto va a ser
exactamente igual am y ya está muy fácil
ahora sí voy a obtener la respuesta de
multiplicar a la matriz inversa de
actores vector columna b que por cierto
es justo lo que nosotros queremos es el
vector columna x ok justo este de aquí y
bueno esto pase exactamente igual y esto
ya está muy sencillo me quedaría el
vector columna uno menos uno así que con
todo esto ya mostramos que esto es
exactamente igual al vector columna uno
menos uno o de otra manera el vector
columna x es igual al vector uno menos
uno o lo que es lo mismo y eso déjame
escribirlo aquí porque es muy importante
el vector columna st y déjame ponerlo
con sus respectivos colores el vector
columna acepten ok éste va a ser igual
al vector columna uno menos uno al
vector columna uno menos uno o lo que es
lo mismo
dicho de otra manera ese va a ser igual
a uno y te va a ser igual a menos
1 y ya con eso tenemos la solución del
problema y estoy seguro que tú estarás
pensando y bueno lo dije en el vídeo
pasado pero lo voy a repetir hoy es 'la
porque usar este método que es más largo
si podemos utilizar el método de suma
resta o sustitución o lo que sea de una
manera directa y bueno de hecho estoy de
acuerdo contigo pero es que esta técnica
es muy útil cuando estás tratando con
problemas computacionales en donde
tienes una situación por ejemplo en la
que el lado izquierdo de la ecuación
este de aquí sea el mismo mientras que
el lado derecho está cambiando es decir
les des muchos pero muchos valores
distintos para el lado derecho de estas
ecuaciones y esto porque va a ser mucho
más fácil que obtengas solamente una vez
la inversa de la matriz y la mantengas
multiplicando por cualquier vector
columna vez que necesites y seguramente
estás un poco familiarizado con esto
pues si tú tienes un procesador gráfico
o una tarjeta de gráficos en tu
computadora y estos hacen unos procesos
gráficos especiales pues todo esto es en
realidad un soporte físico o un soporte
especial de multiplicaciones de matrices
de una manera muy rara
porque cuando estás haciendo
procesamiento gráfico estarás pensando
en modelar cosas en tres dimensiones y
haces todas estas transformaciones
realmente lo que estás haciendo es estas
multiplicaciones de matrices de una
manera muy pero muy pero muy rápida en
tiempo real así que cuando estás jugando
un juego de vídeo lo que sea se siente
como tener una realidad en tres
dimensiones en tiempo real pero de
cualquier manera solo quería realizar
esto si me tomo esta parte de acáp de
una manera aleatoria de manera azarosa
pues mi primer instinto resolverlo por
eliminación pero deberías de pensar que
esta definición de ecuación de matrices
es un concepto muy pero muy útil no
solamente en la computación porque si tú
estudias algunas ciencias a niveles muy
altos especialmente la física vas a ver
un montón de ecuaciones matricial es
como esta
tal vez las encuentres de una manera muy
general pero es muy importante que
pienses en qué representa realmente esta
expresión y en cómo las puedes resolver